bonjour à tous une vidéo pour vous aider
à savoir quel smartphone samsung ht dans
le haut de gamme vous ai déjà fait des
vidéos pour vous parler de la gamme jeep
d'entrée de gamme du moyen de gamme de
la gamma et là on va concentrer sur le
haut de gamme la gamme s et la gamme
d'offres et on y va
samsung a beaucoup de produits
différents à tous les prix et c'est
assez compliqué de savoir quels produits
achetés parce qu'il faut c'est retrouver
dans cette gamme est ce vous avez le s6
s6 et s7 est cette age et suite
elle suit plus s9 s9 plus on va rajouter
la gamme note avec le note 8
tout simplement parce que le notw utile
et un petit peu tout seul aujourd'hui le
no27 c'est un fiasco complet et si
aujourd'hui seules produits coureurs
trou dans la gamme note sur le site de
samsung attendent la sortie du galaxy
note 9 en fin d'année pour l'instant à
se centrer sur tous ses produits et
savoir quel smartphone samsung ht dans
le haut de gamme avec la gamme ne s'en
trouve en tout 1 9 smartphones
c'est un petit peu le bazar savoir quels
produits achetés d'ailleurs toutes ces
dites moi si vous en avez un ou si vous
en avez eu un lequel avait voué lequel
vous intéresserait potentiellement pour
marquer tout ça en commentaire comme ça
on va pouvoir un petit peu discuter si
vous avez des questions si vous avez des
informations de riz des conseils je
pense que toutes les infos sont les
bienvenus il faut savoir que dans le
haut de gamme vous retrouver avec des
écrans au minimum en super amoled en
quad hd du 2560 par 1600 40 pixels alors
globalement dans cette gamme s les
smartphones sont plutôt bons si vous
partez même sur un ace 6 vous aura
smartphone d'une bonne qualité donc vous
inquiétez pas n'est pas tombé sur un
truc un petit peu bancal en vous disant
est-ce que j'ai pas regretter mon achat
ce que je peux vous conseiller néanmoins
par rapport à ces produits le risque
vous avez en allant sur les s6 et s6
heads et les produits qui date un petit
peu qui forcément vont moins bien
vieillir qui auront moins de performance
par rapport aux produits actuels et qui
seront bien moins performant en termes
de photographie par rapport aux os 9
c'est une certitude
elle suit c'est sûr aussi s est way
le ciss fait quand même la faire mais
bon si vous avez un petit budget
supérieur mieux vaut manger tout de
suite soit sur 1,7 1,8 ou alors
carrément sur le nouveau produit de
cette année le galaxy s 9 la différence
vous la connaissez entre le 6 et 6 aides
g7 et s est edge sont les bords incurvés
bon mise à part ça il n'y a pas
énormément de différences donc on va
traiter le s6 comme un smartphone à part
entière même si on parle du 6 et du sii
strange pareil pour le set
si vous vous concentrez sur les six vais
pouvoir faire de bonnes photos un
capteur de 16 mégapixels ouverture de f
1.29 à l'avant une caméra un peu
yens 2 5 mégapixels vous ferez quand
même des vidéos en 4k uhd en 3840 par
2160 pixels n'avait pas cherché sur 1 6
et 1 600 les plus grosses performances
vous aurez un produit haut de gamme qui
fait franchement la faire après si vous
voulez quelque chose d'un peu plus fun
avec des autocollants avec des filtres
quelque chose d'un peu sexy je conseille
d'aller sur le high 8,2 cette année qui
pour moi très quand même un peu plus
cool
même si vous n'avez qu'une résolution en
full hd 1920 par 1080 le produit quand
même hyper sympa avec la double caméra à
l'avant pour les modes portrait pour les
photos pour la vidéo ça fait vraiment
bien la faire figurer pas en 4k c'est
pas grave mais vous aurez en tout cas un
produit qui sera quand même beaucoup
plus sexy
il faut quand même savoir que le à huit
vous coûtera plus cher que le s6 en
assises des poutres aux alentours des 3
120 350 380 euros alors que le n8
il est aux alentours des 499 euros à
noter que si vous voulez opté pour un
est 6 h qui se rapproche un peu plus du
prix deux à huit ans nous entourent des
440 450 euros prenaient qui est super
sympa dans la gamme s c'est le s7 un
produit que je trouve moi vraiment cool
et qui se démode pas énormément alors
effectivement point de vue design on
n'est pas sur les écrans infiniti on
n'est pas sur les bords dans l'est ce
qu'on retrouve à partir du et suit mais
il fait quand même plutôt bien la faire
les photos sont de bonne qualité en
faible luminosité il est super côté
vidéo pareil c'est très bien quatre cas
usage d un design vers un étal bon mois
jeunes à leur reprocher sauf que le s
est plutôt bien
maintenant je trouve qu'il vieillit pas
forcément super bien d'ailleurs tout
comme les six parce que il faut imaginer
que samsung depuis l'année dernière avec
les galaxy s suit ensuite plus cette
année s 9 s9 plus est avec la gamme
notant le note suite ils ont vraiment
mis une claque quand même en terme de
design l'écran bord à bord c'est
vraiment quelque chose de super le
format 18 points 5/9 est magnifique et
tout ça effectivement sentence un petit
peu ringardisé les modèles précédents
néanmoins si vous craignez pas le look
du essaie tous de cet âge
à mon avis vous pouvez y aller
tranquillement parce que c'est vraiment
un super produit côté batterie vous avez
des batteries de 3000 migrants perdre
c'est ce que vous retrouvez d'ailleurs
sur le galaxy s 9 et sur galaxy et suite
vous avez un androïde 6 du bluetooth 4.0
bon voilà c'est pas un produit qui est
hyper récent mais qui fonctionne très
bien
vous apporterez 7 aux alentours de 549
euros et le est cette aide aux alentours
et 699 euros
bon fondamentalement le hais cette age
vous prenez quand même quasiment au même
prix du et suit actuellement les suites
que vous retrouvez à 709 euros sur le
site de samsung dont je pense que
fondamentalement faux pas s'embêter à
aller sur le s est edge aller
directement sur la suite maintenant on
va parler du est suite elles chuté suite
plus alors ça je pense que vous avez
entendu énormément parlé sont les
smartphones haut de gamme les flactif de
samsung sont sortis l'année dernière des
premiers qui pour moi ne se démode pas
du tout vous avez effectivement le s9
qui va très loin en termes de
photographie avec la double ouverture
mais je trouve que vraiment c est suite
et elle suit plus
ils font vraiment bien la faire ils sont
encore dans le game comme on dirait
vraiment dans le game vous avez un super
écran infiniti le borderless est
magnifique
la qualité est juste incroyable 5,8
pouces pour le f8 6,2 pouces pour le s
suit plus capteur photo du à pixel 12
mégapixels avec une ouverture de 1.7 en
termes de luminosité c'est juste dingue
capteurs selphy 8 mégapixels avec une
ouverture de f
1.7 ça marche aussi très très bien vous
filmez enquête cas urgent d vous avez 4
gigas de ram 64 go de stockage
vous pouvez monter jusqu'à 256 giga avec
une carte micro sd en plus de l'usb t-il
ses doubles tout 5.0 enfin un produit
qui est hyper sexy un produit est quand
même baissé parce qu'elle année dernière
faut savoir quand il est sorti le s lui
coûter 1 809 euros et la suite plus 909
euros
vous les retrouvez aujourd'hui 100 euros
de moins 709 euros pour la suite et 809
euros pour le elle suit plus après
fondamentalement je trouve que acheter
le lait suit plus ou tarif du s9 c'est
vraiment une bêtise parce que le s9 va
vraiment plus loin en termes de photos a
effectivement vous avez qu'à l'écran 5,8
pouces n'est pas du 6,2 pouces mais bon
est-ce que vous avez vraiment besoin
d'un écran c'est un coup de pouce parce
que les points positifs que vont nous
apporter le s9 sont vraiment
suffisamment fort pour vous faire
oublier les quelques pouces des cartes
vous avez entre 900 et 1 et suit plus le
s9 c'est vraiment pour moi le photophone
de l'année alors effectivement et les
produits sont très très bons ailleurs
notamment chez huawei chez apple
également avec l'iphone 10 des
smartphones qui sont super et qui font
très bonnes photos mais il ya vraiment
une révolution avec cette ouverture
variable et ça c'est vraiment un point
extrêmement fort chez samsung on va
vraiment toute leur capacité à innover
et à proposer quelque chose qui
correspond vraiment aux besoins
du grand public c'est à dire qu'en mode
automatique vous vous rendrez même pas
compte du changement d'ouverture en mode
pro c'est vous qui allez régler vous
aller encore plus loin dans vos
paramétrages de vos photos mais vraiment
ça vous permettra d'avoir des clichés en
faible luminosité qui seront vraiment
dingue avec une ouverture la plus petite
f 1.5 le processeur aussi et 30 % plus
rapide que le modèle précédant mon côté
batterie c'est kif kif vous avez d'un
côté 4 gigas de ram pour le s9 si giga
de ram pour le s9 plus tu tournes bien
sûr sur android 8.0 oreo vais retrouver
respectivement à 8 59 euros et à 959
euros pour le s9 plus pour maintenant il
faut pas oublier un produit c'est quand
même le note 8 parce que nos tweets
c'est aussi un excellent produit avec un
écran infiniti du borderless très grand
écran mais ça mon sens un produit un peu
à part un peu à part parce que c'est un
produit avec un s pen c'est à dire un
style et un stylet qui marchent
superbement bien mais c'est un produit
dont il faut vraiment avoir l'utilité
rien ne sert d'acheter ce produit quand
même plus de 1000 euros on est à 1900
euros actuellement c'est quelque chose
qui est très cher on va pas se mentir
mais par contre c'est vraiment un
produit qui est top
vous avez un écran quad hd + 2 1960 par
1440 pixels 6,3 pouces super amoled
vous avez un double capteur photo
l'arrière 12 mégapixels 12 mégapixels
une ouverture f 1.7 et une ouverture f
2.4 à l'avant vous avez un capteur de 8
mégapixels une ouverture de f
1.7 bon il filme en 4k joue pas c'est un
peu l'histoire vous avez si giga de ram
64 go de stockage que vous pouvez monter
jusqu'à 256 giga de l'usb tilt c'est
d'ubuntu 5.0 de la prise biac tout ce
que vous voulez c'est vraiment un
produit qui est hyper sexy mais la
question à se poser là dedans c'est pas
se demander si on a choisi entre a et
suit un ace neuf ou alors un autre 8 la
question c'est est-ce que vous avez
besoin de ce noeud de suite est ce que
le style est vraiment vous apporter
quelque chose à ce que la prise de notes
rapides comme ça cela vous servir à
quelque chose
est ce que vous êtes un dessinateur si
pour moi vous n'êtes pas dessinateur pas
infographiste savait pas besoin de
l'utiliser une crique fouillée tout le
temps je vois vraiment pas l'intérêt
d'acheter ce produit qui coûte
aujourd'hui comme je vous le dis 1900
euros
à mon sens la question doit se poser
entre trois produits dans le haut de
gamme le 7 le suit et le s9 est ce que
vous voulez vraiment faire des photos
quasi quasi pro 1 on n'est pas non plus
sur un reflex on n'est pas vraiment sur
cette typologie de produits
mais si vous voulez faire des sucres
photo od très bonne vidéo le s9
clairement c'est la bête de compet
il faut aller dessus si maintenant vous
voulez un bon smartphone et que le
l'écran infiniti le design borderless
n'est pas votre truc
le set est super bien et un super
rapport qualité prix si maintenant vous
aimez le design border à l'aise que vous
voulez un écran infiniti mais vous
voulez pas mettre énormément d'argent ce
qui est déjà quand même beaucoup
d'argent le et suit le fil tout quand
même cher mais est vraiment super voilà
un peu à mon sens c'est la différence
entre ces produits dans le haut de gamme
il y en a trois principaux j'exclus
vraiment le nom de suite parce que pour
moi c'est un produit à part qui
s'adresse vraiment à des personnes qui
ont une réelle utilité du spn pour moi
les deux produits les plus sexys soit
effectivement le et suites et le s9 bien
évidemment le s7 est toujours dans le
game tout simplement parce que il est
encore super très très bon produit
donc voilà un peu à mon sens la
différence vous avez quand même recette
qu'il ya 549 euros
contrairement au s 9 qui est quand même
à 809 euros dont il ya quand même un
vrai écart de budget ça se calcule parce
que si vous avez un budget à 500 euros
voire un peu plus mais vous n'avez pas
le budget pour un snuff vous prenez un
sel vous serez vraiment pas déçu
d'ailleurs dit moi vous ce que vous en
pensez ce que vous avez déjà eu des
produits de la gamme s chez samsung s
est ensuite s 9 aces 6 pourquoi pas vous
marquez tout ça en commentaire on va en
discuter ensemble
est-ce que vous avez un autre tweet est
ce que vous l'avez essayé qu'elle
produit pourrait vous intéresser
et si vous en avez un dites nous ce que
vous en pensez pour que on partage un
petit peu notre expérience et pouvoir
s'entraider et savoir quel est le
produit le plus sexy comme d'hab je vous
invite à laisser des jolies pousse à
rester connectés parce que il ya plein
de guides d'achat de comparatifs pour
vous aider dans vos achats
concrètement dans vos différences
parfois nous mêmes dans plein d'autres
produits qu'on peut imaginer
chez samsung comme je voulais dit on a
regardé la gabegie la gamme à la gamme s
on regarde aussi un petit récap complet
pour savoir un petit peu qu'elle ait
produit le smartphone le plus
intéressant en 2018 a acheté chez
samsung
comme d'hab je vous remercie je n'ai
jamais cédé jolie pousse à vous abonner
on reste connectés fait des gros bisous
et puis je vous dis à très bientôt tiens
[Musique]